[Music]
that was
an incredible audition on american idol
last night from teen trans singer a
styles
who also shared his powerful journey
with fans of the show
it became super confusing i definitely
had to come out to myself before i
decided to come out to everybody else
but when i was 14 i had a moment of
realization if you will
he sat me down in his room and he said
mom i've got to tell you something
i'm a boy and i said okay
it's the way that that's it and ace also
shared how he felt
after coming out my mom was definitely a
big part in
me being happy it's so amazing to
be okay with yourself again and like
it's kind of like
relearning how to love yourself now even
after his powerful audition
on the show last night idol judges katy
perry luke bryan
and lionel richie decided to not move
ace forward
in the competition i i think he's just
not quite ready for american idol yet
i was good enough and i thought that i
was worth it
now what really bothered me and a lot of
fans is that
ace was turned away and a pitbull
impersonator
moved forward we got a boogie boogie
boogie wiggle and dance
like the roof on fire
now after watching both performances do
you agree with me that ace
should have moved forward in the
competition let me know in the comments
below
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews
click subscribe or watch these videos